Oh my god, this is actually the perfect example. Thank you so
so so much. What was he going to juggle us on different days?
That's crazy. I'm back into predatory is fine. Predator predator
predatory totally appropriate for this guy. This guy is scum.
So they'll defend this because they have to defend this because
this is precisely the behavior they want to engage in either
in the future or that they're engaging in now.
>> Guys, is there anybody in the Twitch chat or the Kick
chat who's unaware of the Sykkuno allegations? So Sykkuno
had an allegation drop on April 10th. That's 1 week ago today.
The allegation heavy-handed in how it was titled. I believe the
woman who wrote the Google Doc was calling him a predator. The
Google Doc itself actually alleged a pattern of manipulation
and lying to like in order to sleep with these people. So he
had a girlfriend Sykkuno had a long-term girlfriend and you find
out that his girlfriend is very upset that he's been going behind
her back of other people. All of this stuff comes out that he's
basically lying to and manipulating young women. We'll say smaller
VTubers. Some of the women were like 24 25 26. I'm not going
to treat them like they're kids. He does like the nice guy rizz,
right? Where he's like he tries to present himself as non-threatening
consistently until eventually you like basically be incredibly
inconvenient not to him is what it seems like. 2 days ago maybe
3 days ago now. So Sykkuno actually posted a response and he
basically said yeah I'm sorry I lied but I also I'm not a predator
so that was weird. Anyway, here's my girlfriend. So he kind of
apologized for the things he'd done and said but also I'm not
a predator so what the heck. And then his girlfriend who through
the document and other statements we learned that she's very
upset. She was like very very upset about this. She was talking
about leaving him and he convinced her to stay and the rest of
the statement is just her saying like these other women who came
out and made my private business public. And to me it's just
a little it smacks of some okay. But now as of today we get a
brand new accuser. All right? So we're just looking April 16th.
That's yesterday morning was when Sykkuno's message came out
with his from his girlfriend and him, okay? And now today April
17th we find out that we've got there's more to the story, okay?
There's more to the story. There's another accuser. I didn't
think anyone else was going to come out cuz honestly the public
is super against these people. The public is very very upset
with these people and like and I think they will be upset with
just anybody who's accusing Sykkuno of anything short of like
or
I think they'll go oh this doesn't matter. Why was it this kept
private? Every time, okay? Every time. But you know it is what
it is and without further ado I'm going to get into the actual
Google Doc. This is the new Sykkuno allegation.
All right. After reading both the private and public apologies
I do not feel reassured. This is part of why I'm choosing to
share my experience now.
I also believe people can make more informed decisions when they
have more context not less. Sykkuno became my friend when I was
17 and he was 28. Nothing inappropriate happened at that time
but that history shaped the trust I had in him later. Okay. This
document is a personal account of my experience.
A lot of communication occurred over calls so there is limit
limited written
I've tried to include as much as I can. Readers can use their
own judgment. Before people read this and dismiss it as more
of the same drama part of why I'm making my experience public
now is because both his private and public apologies have left
me feeling unsettled. To me they left they have often felt more
like explanations or excuses than meaningful
That has been part of what pushed me to speak because I do not
personally feel reassured that there's been genuine reflection
and I would rather others in the space have more information
than less. That's one thing with like the people who do reflexively
defend here is you do prevent like people who have genuinely
bad behaviors from becoming
You do just you prevent them from becoming like better people.
This isn't meant to promote harassment, hate, or negativity towards
anyone involved. I'm sharing it to provide context for my experience
and to highlight patterns that stood out to me. After reading
all the public statements from other girls I found myself reflecting
on these events and how I I understand his girlfriend did not
want the initial story to be made public and I reached out to
her beforehand as a With so much in the open I feel I have the
a right to share my story as I've been left feeling used and
misled. With so much in the open I feel that I have the a right
to share my story as I've been left feeling used and misled.
I will be talking about some very personal things here which
are quite frankly embarrassing to share but I feel are pertinent
to understanding my why I feel so deeply affected by this. Quite
frankly embarrassing to share that's our favorite stuff. That's
like the best content. Would this be very would this be like
horrifyingly embarrassing if it came out about you or you had
to share it? Yeah? Oh well that's listen everybody here terrible
people who just love to see other people go through embarrassment
and and shame and hard
That's the content. TLDR I became friends with him when I was
a minor 17 and we remained friendly for several
More recently he made advances toward me and told me he was not
involved with anyone else. I later found out that was not true.
Had I known I wouldn't have become involved beyond a friendship
due to past trauma. I'm sharing this because from what I experienced
and what I've heard this did not feel like an isolated
Also I know mucho texto and pages but fear not most of it is
just Discord DMs sort of. How I met Sykkuno.
We met through a mutual friend who connected us and he reached
out to me first. This was before I became a VTuber so I've censored
my old account name account's name and profile picture. I want
to be very clear that he did not do anything explicit with me
when I was a minor. Our conversations were casual. We talked
about games like Arknights and Animal Crossing, played Ark together,
and just chatted. I'm including some screenshots for context.
I'm including this because I think it is relevant to the overall
dynamic. There's about an 11-year age difference between us so
when I was 17 he was around 28. All screenshots in this section
are from when I was underage.
March 6th 2020.
Sent her a YouTube video lmao but wait why are you messaging
me? I I heard you like Arknights and you were you were blank
friend. Sorry never mind. No I do I do. No I I do. Ah I just
didn't expect you to talk to me. Yes I'm a slave for all the
waifus and husbandos on there. And so is my wallet. But yes I
like Arknights and I am blank friend. Hi. lol all right I added
you. Sykkuno started a call that lasted 2 hours.
>> Okay. I mean if he never made any inappropriate moves
at all it's like it's I'm not calling him a PDF for this, okay?
It's it is weird. I do think it's
But I don't know what to say beyond weird. Like he also I don't
know if he has any idea how old she is, right?
It seemed like this guy just had a like a penchant for any woman
involved I'm going to message them and try to hang out with them.
Again it is like the nice guy rizz where you were going to like
just talk to people and try to make it like so when you finally
pull your out it is just way too inconvenient to their life to
not suck it.
Like literally he's going to build up a friendship a reliance
on him monetarily. Like they're going to be staying in his place.
There's going to be just so many barriers so that when he finally
pulls his out they're like half I guess so it'd be really inconvenient
to do anything else.
That's that's like the system that he is putting into play here
I feel like.
Uh about 4K hours on it and is PvP God so we'll get carried yay.
Oh God
yeah I actually yeah I actually
it's a fun game. I don't think I'm that fun. Don't know anyone
who plays. I bought the game a while ago to play with a friend
I had but they never talked to me again so
>> What do you have so don't worry about That seems to
be the pattern. You are super nice and easy to talk to though
so thank you. That was actually my first time playing lol. Oh
no I'm sorry. It's okay don't worry.
Well you have me now. The only reason I will stop talking to
you is if I get kidnapped. Well that goes for all my friends
really cuz I have nothing to do but talk to them. So yeah if
I don't respond call the FBI. You um all right. I unless I'm
the one doing the kidnap. I'm so I'm dude I'm sorry.
>> JK lol JK lol. Bro I'm sorry. I don't know what to tell
you but this is
This is this is worse than if he was just like I I swear to god
if he was just trying to this 17-year-old I would be less grossed
out by this human being. I'm not even kidding. If he had just
been like hey I'll give you $500 if you send me a picture of
I SWEAR TO GOD I'D BE LESS grossed out by this person.
I'm not even I'm not even I'm not joking. I am fully serious.
That at least I understand. This is like weird as [__]
This is so weird to me man. Wait she's 17? This girl is 17 right
now. Put me in suitcase. UW what?
I will illegally go to Cali haha no need to pay. It's called
saving money.
At least dude this is what she said. Bro does she know that she's
cooking this
Listen. Listen guys I want to be very clear that he did not do
anything explicit with me while I was a minor. Our conversations
were casual.
How is this casual? Where is this
What what the hell?
What the Oh my god. Okay. This is this woman understands okay?
She may be I guess 2020 she was 17 so she's
uh 25 now? But she understands how to do this thing, okay? As
Oh hello Max thank you for the 13 months appreciate it. As President
Donald Trump says, actually everybody says this.
Under sell, over deliver, all right? Under sell, over deliver.
This is This is what you do. It makes it punch harder, okay?
We need to go back to Where were we here? Right here. At least
you wouldn't need to fight for arm room. I always get stuck in
the middle on planes. Finally, I'll have space all to myself.
First class flying. LOL, um I I don't know if my suitcase is
a large enough to a
I'm just sending you random videos that I've saved, honestly.
Oh.
So
is what you are into.
Huh? Wait, did I do something wrong? I'm
Huh? You didn't I was just messing around with you a little.
Huh? So sorry. LOL
Oh, 20 28 years old at this time, guys. 28 years old at this
time. Oh, I didn't know. Ah, it's fine. I'm just The jokes go
over my head.
Again, I was minor at the time.
I understand at the end of the day, these were just jokes. But
looking back, him making jokes now that I now feel have connotations
from the get-go feels very off-putting. Oh my god, this is actually
the perfect example. Thank you so so so much, random girl who
got groomed as a year old,
this is what I mean when people can actually retroactively look
at a situation and get a better understanding of it, and it's
not like retroactively
uh rescinding consent. It's like, dude, she didn't think anything
was wrong with this when she thought this guy was like actually
a loser, actually like didn't know how to talk to women. But
when you realize that this is him doing something he's done with
like a hundred other girls at least.
You go look at it again, and now under this new lens, yeah, we
can all see that this is weird.
Right? We can all see that it's weird. It's obvious it's weird
now. Yeah, I So, people get so mad when someone comes out, they're
like, oh, this changed how I view the situation. That's not pretending
That's not regretting it and then not consenting.
That's like, now you have more information to relook at the situation
and evaluate it correctly.
Shockingly, people will act like, oh, when he did this with like
an 18 or 19-year-old,
that's like magically universe just universally different than
when he did it with a 17-year-old.
But it's like the same thing in essence, barring the arbitrary
line, right?
Like in terms of the experience in It's legally very different
if they'd done anything, right? And I understand the the difference.
I understand the differentiation. But I'm saying that realistically,
in terms of the life experience, there's probably not a very
much There's probably not a lot different between an 18-year-old
and this girl. You know what I'm saying? What? So, you're going
to poke me like one time, then the dinosaur will kill me?
uh LOL J J JK Wait, how are you responding while streaming? Also,
your hair looks really nice today.
Multitasking smile. Ah, thanks. I didn't really do anything to
it. Ah, yes, with
Oh god. Oh god, it naturally looks nice.
Dang it. I look like a hobo because of the quarantine.
I need a haircut. LOL
My hair used to be pretty short, but now it's growing out. Ah
Nah, your hair is fine. What do you mean? It does look like it
annoys your eyes, but other than that Oh god, LOL uh Do you prefer
hair short or long? On me? Short, easier to maintain, and it
doesn't like my like swap my face as
Oh, yeah, short is nice, I think. I used to have super long hair,
and it was so it was so hard to wash and maintain. Uh uh uh What
about you?
Oh, uh I prefer short, too, actually. I think long hair can look
nice, though. But shorter hair is nicer for hugs and uh stuff.
Ah, I don't know. Both are good.
>> And uh stuff and uh stuff.
Do you think if you code this as if you're a child? I don't know
what and uh stuff is. You think I don't know what and uh stuff
means, brother? Come on, man. Come on. Be honest, be serious,
be
We all know what and uh stuff means,
Hey, men, for you.
Oh, oops, caps. Sorry. But yes, both are good. Oh, uh for me,
uh I prefer shorter-ish, I guess, but not like super short, but
not super long. There, so like normal length guy hair. LOL uh
yeah, normal, I guess. Uh I don't know. During this time, I was
a face cam streamer. He would sometimes pop in my stream. I never
thought much about his comments on my appearance while I was
a minor, but going back and reading things like short hair is
nice for hugs and uh stuff, and the implication in it makes me
feel disgusted. I had short hair at this time.
Yeah, no, it's actually it is inappropriate. Again, I don't know
how old he thought she was. Like, I don't know if he knew, right?
Not that he would have been checking. Bro, and I'm sorry.
Nobody Nobody has the strength to ask what I'm about to ask,
except for me,
But realistically, what did you look like at the time? I I It
is important to know for science.
Literally just like, do you look like you're 14? Cuz 17-year-olds
can look 17, but they can look like 13, too, okay? Which one
was she? Which one was he doing this whole role play with? Cuz
it makes a difference. Cuz trust me, if you're getting into these
VTuber spaces, if you're getting chatted up by Saiykoono's friends,
you are probably one of those younger-looking people. I'm telling
you you look like you I'm guessing you are one of those way way
way younger-looking people. Yeah, she's definitely high chance
she's way younger if she's like one of his friends with one of
his friends, right? How old was he at the time again? 28.
He's talking like this at 28. OH, NO.
>> IF HE DIDN'T know how old she was,
then this is going to really drive that home, isn't it? If he
didn't know,
This looks like a tweet, like an embedded tweet, right? Yeah,
it is an embedded tweet. Oh, boy.
Hey there. You're invited to my 18th birthday
Since I can't have one IRL, I will be having one with my friends
and chat. We'll be doing doodles, Jackbox, and other fun stuffs.
Decided if I can't have a party, may as well have one big one
online, if that makes sense. If you are free, you're warmly welcomed.
Oh my god. When is this? Sunday? So Sunday?
Oh god, it is It's at 5:00 a.m. my time. Maybe I can come near
the end, maybe. Yeah, cuz it goes on till 10:00 p.m., which is
2:00 p.m. your time. Bro, why do they type the uhs? Why are you
typing the uhs? Yeah, I hear it. I hear it. I know. I appreciate
it. Obviously, don't feel obliged, though I totally understand.
You're invited to my 18th birthday celebration. I censored the
months because I don't want my exact birthday to be public knowledge.
I want to keep as much personally identifiable information as
possible private, given how I am sharing so many other deeply
personal things in further in the document. Same Same to you.
When is this?
You seem super friendly, so don't let people, um you know, take
advantage or something, too. There's a certain level of irony
to this.
>> That's funny.
Why I trusted him. I knew him for over 5 years, and we would
communicate sporadically throughout the entire time and play
games here and I had never heard anything bad about him. I'd
only positive interactions with him. He is was a respected content
creator in the space with a lot of
His persona on streams was very wholesome. He was flirty, but
nothing over the top. And honestly, I usually didn't even pick
up on it. When Peak became popular, he started inviting me to
into group
After that, we ended up Peak um What game is this Peak? It's
got to be a four-letter or a four-word game name, right? I actually
don't know. Anyway,
somebody should tell me. Friend slot game? I mean video game?
Okay, okay. Oh, it's just called Peak. It's literally just called
Peak. I got it. Yeah, yeah, yeah, I got it. Got it. Got it. Got
it. Got it. Got it. After that, we ended up gaming together pretty
regularly, both on and off stream. Sometimes it was just the
two of us. Other times, one of his friends would join in. He
also opened up to me about personal things, his family, his childhood,
and experiences he hadn't shared publicly. At one point, he even
gave me his phone number, which felt like a clear sign that he
trusted me.
Relevant personal context. I dropped out of school at age 15
due to being extremely mentally unwell.
>> Yeah, that's uh Listen.
There's That's a really low chance you meet anybody random in
the real world that they'll say that. But when you're reading
a Google document, okay? Way higher chance of that being the
case. Way higher. Like, there's probably a five-ish percent chance,
as soon as you're reading a Google document, that that's what
happened. I am not a very balanced individual. And anyone who's
interacted with me for longer than 10 minutes would be able to
tell. I struggle with autism, ADHD, OCD, GAD, and an eating disorder.
These are not meme illnesses I've been collecting like Pokémon
patches.
Well, I'm happy I didn't make that joke, but real conditions
that have been medically diagnosed by professionals.
I would love nothing more than to be a normal individual. I also
have the self-confidence of a wet rat. I was very honest about
this with him and talked about how low my self-esteem was and
body how low my self-esteem and body
Or sorry, talked about my low self-esteem and body issues.
I'm not sharing this as an excuse or a way to remove myself of
accountability, but I think it adds context as to why I feel
I am more vulnerable to being taken advantage of. I struggle
to understand people, and I was bullied badly before I dropped
out of school. I've never had a boyfriend, been in a proper long-term
relationship, or slept with anyone. I have little to no real-world
experience. I trusted Saiykoono, despite deep trauma that I'm
not going to air out, and I feel disgusted looking in the mirror
sometimes knowing what I sent him sent to him and that I was
just another goal.
The funny thing about this is it does it's it's literally the
most
balanced Google Doc I've read in a long time. Like it's not overstating
things and it's saying, "Hey, I'm giving you this context not
because it like makes me not culpable, but because it is like
relatively important."
Right? They're not just like leaning into it and saying nothing
else.
They're trying to keep it balanced, try not to, you know, get
out over their skis. I think this person sounds like more balanced
and more reasonable than most other Google Docs I've read, which
I guess isn't necessarily a high bar, but it's funny that they're
like, "Well, I'm I'm super like broken."
Well, it doesn't sound I wouldn't get that impression from reading
the rest of the document, okay? How the relationship became more
than friendship. We mostly interacted in group settings, but
once it was just the two of us after a third person left. During
that conversation, his interest seemed to shift when he learned
I never I had never had
It was during these calls that he started making romantic advances.
I mentioned I was up late due to medication side effects, and
when I said I was on the pill, he seemed surprised and assumed
I was active. I clarified that I wasn't. I can be very blunt
at times. He's a huge successful streamer with lots of connections,
status, wealth, etc. I don't think I'm special and I have very
low self-esteem. So, a few times I asked him, "Why me?" As in,
"Why would you choose me when you could have anyone he wanted?"
Or when he could have anyone he wanted. His response was, "I
trust you." Oh, dude, it is it's like all of the
>> Ew, it's
it's all of Dude, it's just all of the
Like this is and people don't care. People think this is nothing,
right? But it it actually is and this is how you build like deep-seated
trust issues in other people. It's like there has to be some
way to teach people that you should act in the world to not hurt
other people emotionally, too. Not just like financially or physically,
but like you can actually You can do certain things. You can
restrict certain behaviors that don't place any one of your whims
above like the core
well-being and and trust of other humans. It's not difficult,
man.
You know what I'm saying? Like Like clearly and again at this
time, he doesn't mean like I trust you, you're special in some
way. He is just like raising up a bunch of these girls in DMs.
Right? That is what's happening
She's not special to him. These are
And he is just going to build massive trust issues in this person
because he doesn't care. He just wants He wants like some satisfaction
or even just the obsession of this girl and he doesn't care about
what it costs her to get it. Yeah. Yeah, I mean he is He is.
I And like I it sounds super sad to say this, but it's not difficult
to to like be better than this. It's really not.
I don't know. It's
Uh you just breed like such crazy trust issues in people. Anyway,
his response was, "I trust you." I believe this. Again, I had
no reason not to and it logically made sense. I had a positive
track record with him. Also, given the nature of his of his substantially
female audience, he would want something under the radar and
he trusted me to be discreet.
When the conversation started to become much more romantic, I
directly asked if he was involved with other girls and made it
clear I wanted to know up front. He denied it and that reassured
me at the time.
Had I known he was seeing multiple girls and inviting them to
conventions, I wouldn't have gotten involved. I only engaged
with him based on what I now believe were false pretenses. I
thought he really liked me and this would eventually lead to
a relationship.
The call ended with what sounded to me like cough and heavy breathing
after sending him a picture of me.
Boy, oh boy, that's a rough one. He was the initiator in everything
romantic and flirtatious. I simply followed his lead. The screenshots
below are of him asking for his prize to be from behind, the
prize in question being an explicit photo of me. He would play
Mancala We would play Mancala with each other and I won most
of the time.
Go on, have another, why don't you? So, about my prize. What
prize? You haven't won yet. I'm drawing this out. I'm holding
you hostage. I want my present from behind next time.
One reply. What? Can you actually draw it out? LOL. Wait, this
is actually going to take like 20 turns. My final revenge. Okay.
Is what I would say if you had won. Unfortunately, I'm a sore
loser and I'm go now going to be stubborn and not move my pebble.
I guess it's a tie. What? LOL. No way. Oh my god. Wink. Haha.
No. How about a fair game of archery? Besides, I'm still waiting
for my prize. Only fair to make you wait. Okay, fine, you're
on.
The screenshot below is after I sent him an explicit photo. We
had agreed on a trade, but he never held up his end of the deal.
He did the whole, "I'm so nervous. I've never done anything like
this before. Oh my god." routine. I didn't ask him to send anything
explicit, but seeing as he bragged about his size to me, I wanted
a suggestive photo. I guess it was also a show of trust. He would
always put off sending anything back or make excuses. It's not
the best, but I started working out to try to make it nicer for
you. And I know we said we'd trade, but I wanted you to have
this before I leave. Oh, what the heck, you're so sweet. Thank
you. Oh my god. So, this is January 6th. Is this 2026?
Cuz there's no year here. If it was 2025, it would have a year,
right? Big small confirmed.
He was He was, you know, right? His mouth was writing checks
his body couldn't cash. I'm going about size is right. It's really
not. It's It's really not even that big a deal.
But I think Listen, there's there's there might be something
here. I think I think there could be something here for
like feeling like she didn't get anything back. She's Man, I
I understand this. I I have empathy for this. She's like replaying
all of the interactions they ever had.
So, thank you. I will do it. Oh my god. I'm sorry. To be honest,
I've actually never done anything like that, so I'm nervous and
worried I'll do it bad. Wait, is your trip tomorrow? Oh my god,
it was the 7th, right? No, it's totally okay. I understand. I'm
nervous every time I do stuff. You can keep all your clothes
on, so it shouldn't be too bad, surely. Yeah, I leave tomorrow.
Also, good morning. You woke me up You woke me up. Ehe.
No, it's totally okay. Oh, wait, hold on. I did what? Good morning.
Yeah, I forgot to silence. Hopefully, you're less nervous if
you know I like when I see you. Oh, oh my god, sorry. No, no,
it's really nice being woken up by you.
My brain is half asleep still and I can't understand for the
life of me what you're saying here. Haha.
You said you were nervous when you do stuff. I was trying to
make you feel more comfy comfy. LOL. But you should go back to
sleep. I probably will soon.
All right, I see I see. Okay, well, thanks again for playing.
It was really fun. Hopefully, we can hang out before I
Wow. Okay. This screenshot below was from our last text conversation
in March. He was still flirting with me despite having already
moved out onto another girl.
You're such a cheater. Bad Bad sportsmanship. Big cheating. Unfair
strategy. Big win big. Your underhanded tactics were used, therefore
your win is null and void. Oh, I'll be underhanding. All right.
I'd like to see you Oh, I'd like to see you try.
Request to meet in person. Paris, Europe, TwitchCon.
He'd asked me multiple times, so
March, still flirting. I thought I think we have Discord conversations
from far more recently as well, but let's let's check this out.
So, request to meet in person. Paris, Europe, TwitchCon.
He'd asked me multiple times if I wanted to hang out at TwitchCon
or Paris prior to us becoming involved. Most of the time, I gave
noncommittal answers, redirected the conversation to something
else, or said no. When I said I couldn't go because of money,
he this simp was simply because it was the easiest answer. I
didn't want to explain that I was scared to travel alone to a
foreign country where I knew no one to meet someone for the first
time, that I struggled in crowds, around people, and with other
issues. I was not looking for a handout and declined any offer
to pay for me.
Note, some of these screenshots are just normal DMs between us,
but I thought it would be more transparent if I posted the intact
conversation. The point of including them is to prove that he
meant to fly me and two other girls separately to Paris. Oh,
dude. Wait, hold on. That's another thing that could be really
funny. Imagine he's flown flown out multiple girls to the same
con while saying he's single, but he's flown multiple girls out
and that's why when when one of them walks up to him in person,
he's like so cold about it cuz one of the girls said, "Oh, you
know, he I was going to Las Vegas for some con and once we got
out of the hotel,
like he was really cold to me. You know what I'm saying? Like
he pretended he didn't know me almost. That would be crazy if
we find that out, okay? Also, are you going to hang when I visit
Europe this year? I can't You're going to Europe? Why? Well,
I think Paris specifically. LOL. Have you ever been there? Yeah.
Is Is it an all right place or like LOL? It's very busy. I don't
know. It was a few years back. There's like a TFT tournament
or something there next year. Depends what time you go. I went
outside a public holiday, so it was emptier, but still busy.
Oh, is it hard to get there for you? Not really. Short plane
flight. Go see the Mona Lisa in the Louvre. That's cool. Come
hang with me. Come hang when I'm there. Woo. Accommodation in
Paris is expensive. I'm a broke student. I hope you have fun,
though. What?
Go eat some good French pastry. They do great pastries.
I can
I can probably help with that. Don't worry. Well, it's not
for a while a while. It's not for a while, anyway, but that's
very kind, but you don't need to. I've actually never been to
Europe ever in my life. Sorry, I am reading through this cuz
it's going to be a little slower. Right? I'm practically a stranger
to you. Wait,
Yeah, I actually first traveled overseas to Japan like last year.
I'm trying to think.
For the first time I really traveled. You don't like to travel?
Wow. I hope Japan was nice. I would love to see the cherry blossom
someday. Traveling has always been normal to me cuz the UK is
so tiny. You have to leave if you want if you want to do other
things, but America is so stupidly vast. I can see why most or
many people rarely ever leave the country. Oh, yeah, America's
big. And you're not a stranger. What the heck? We lived in the
same ark house before before it got destroyed by the raptors.
A very cozy house made of mud and straw. God celestial. Oh my
god, brats. We celebrated at TwitchCon.
We must celebrate at TwitchCon.
Oh my god, hi. Morning. Are we hanging out at TwitchCon? I can't
go. I'm broke.
No. Okay, but what about if I went to Paris later this year?
You could go to that. I mean, technically, yes. Wait, really?
But again, money. Is Paris close?
Dude, he's um It is really funny to see that like Do you think
he even wants to go to these
Do you think he if he has nobody to get one of these things,
do you think he even goes? Like if it if one of his dates canceled,
do you think he'd show up? Like I wonder if that's cuz he needs
to find a place where he can go and have like a reasonable excuse
to his girlfriend for why he's traveling. You know what I'm saying?
So, he he basically says, "Okay, he's setting up this con. He's
flying somebody else in." And then he's got to fly back home.
And so I'm thinking like does he if does he really like going
for any of the cons and stuff or is he just going and like basically
when he knows he can meet somebody up meet up with somebody there?
Have a thing going on. No. Make a fresh one and bring it to me
when I'm in Paris. Will you bake me something in return then?
Oh, um I'm bad at baking. I'll buy you some food at from a restaurant.
It's the best I can do. LOL. Oh my god. All right. Can't wait
to try some food when I'm here or when I'm
You should try a croque monsieur when you're in France. Very
tasty. Best grilled cheese as you call it. Oh, and potato dauphinoise.
Oh, and beef bourguignon.
Those are my favorites. Super tasty. Oh my god. I will have to
look for them. Well, why don't we try them together? I already
tried them. This is for you. Well, what if I just wanted to hang
out with you? Oh yeah, I was going to Dude.
It's like this guy has short-term memory loss, right? He's just
Listen. Listen. Listen, guys. What if we did it with you? What
if I What if you came to Europe? What if you came to Europe?
What if you came to Europe? I forgot. What were you saying about
Europe? Do you want to come to Europe? Do you want to come to
you meet me in Europe? I'll fly you up. I'll fly you up. I'll
fly you up. I'll fly you up. I'll fly you up.
Maybe Yeah, maybe there's just so many women that he can't remember.
Maybe he's desperately trying to like figure out a girl to come
to Europe. And so he just keeps going like, "Wait, did I invite
you to Europe yet? Hey, did I invite you? Are you going to Europe?
Are you sure if you're going to Europe?" Oh yeah, I was going
to ask if you've ever been to Paris. Oh, this is this is a huge
red flag.
That's where you figure out for sure that you're not special,
right? After like multiple times talking about Paris, talking
about what you should try in Paris, talking about the French
in a way where you think this is leading to a relationship, apparently.
And then
here in November of 2025, he goes, "Oh yeah, I was going to ask
if you've ever been to Paris?"
That should be the biggest red flag in your head that this guy's
around. That was before. This is November 2025.
I don't think so. I think this is mostly in order, right?
Yeah, no, this is this is 10 months
Where she's talking about go eat some good French pastries. I
think Paris specifically. Have you ever been there? This is
January of 2025. 10 months later, he's going, "Wait, have you
ever been to Paris though?"
That should be That should massively massively flag to you, okay?
Okay. We keep going.
All right. After our more than friendship involvement, when he
invited me to go to Paris again while in a call together, I accepted.
We talked about it in DMs, too. Oh yeah, she's uh This is rough,
man. This is just panic mass message messaging because he has
nobody booked. I That's kind of what I think it is, man. That
is kind of what I think it is. Like he's he's it's getting closer
and closer. Now he's in December of 2025 and he's trying to figure
it out. Hey, planning to go to this thing. I told my girlfriend
I was going and I need somebody to And by the way, we should
figure out when did the Elfi girl cuz I think this is when the
Elfi girl goes to Paris, right? Anyway.
All right. Okay, so you're coming to Paris for the whole weekend
I'm there or LOL. And I'm sort of like sort of kind of up. Do
you want me there? I'm asking you. And to be honest, I'd feel
bad cuz some days I'd probably be super busy with the TFT event
and I wouldn't want you to just be sitting there bored. I love
puzzles. I can do puzzles for hours alone. LOL. What? I'm pretty
good at entertaining myself. That sounds so sad. No. LOL.
Yeah. What? No, it's fun. I like it a lot. What kind of puzzles?
Like the ones you just put together or something?
Good lord.
Ravensburger ones. Yeah, puzzle pieces. I'm practicing for the
retirement home. What can I say? I can easily do a thousand-piece
puzzle in one sitting. It's very cathartic.
I will jump on you to make sure you're
What? LOL. Okay, so you're So, you're going to bring puzzles.
Puzzles multiple? They are kind of big. Oh, well, I think I'm
leaving on the 15th, probably. I was thinking maybe you visit
for like one day or something. Probably. Shouldn't you have everything
booked? What the heck?
I can easily entertain myself for a day. Well, I mean, you could
always change a flight or get a hotel for more nights. Technically,
you can. LOL.
I can I do have free will. That is true. What are you going to
do be doing at the tournament? Playing TFT and stuff. Just watching
Oh, you're a competitor. Yeah. Well, I'll probably lose fast.
Well, how long would you want to be there? Mm. Well, it feels
like a waste to go to Paris and sit in a hotel room for a day
or two. Or for a day. Probably two days so I can walk around
Paris to see things. Just a girl who's terrified of French people
and deep L on her phone.
What could go wrong? Yeah, that would kind of suck. What do you
think? I think it's I think it's be fun. I think so,
Just don't drug me and chop me up into pieces and put me in a
suitcase. Huh? LOL. I don't think that's what it would
Is your schedule like fairly open or Yeah, pretty much apart
from going to South Africa. Oh, okay. Okay, so when is your South
Africa trip again? Mid-January. Okay. Oi, got the dog collar.
Rawr, she. The Maybe this person is on cuz he's trying to set
up times to go meet up in person and she's like playing games.
She's focused on the game.
Congrats. And yeah, it is. Saikouno, which state? Oh, California.
Why do you ask? Man, that's a 12-hour flight. LOL. Yeah, it's
far. Sorry. I mean, it's more Imagine I fly all the way there
and you're like, "Mm, I don't like you very What would you rather
That would be rather Oh my god. Hold on. Hold on. Wait.
Wait. Wait. Wait.
He got another girl confirmed, didn't he? For the event. He got
another girl confirmed for the event itself.
And so now he's either trying to extend to keep her there or
switch up to send her to America.
Right? Cuz I do believe this is when the Elfi girl is meeting
up with him in Paris. And I would want to see when Elfi
said yes to going to Paris.
And now all my god, we see it, don't we?
We see it. We see it. We see it. That's why you got to read everything.
That's why you got to read everything because the the picture
becomes clear.
>> That's why you got to you got to dude. Oh my god. Cuz
now it's like, "Oh no, it would be terrible if you just stayed
in the hotel room. Like maybe I'll I'll maybe I'll just book
you like later and then it'll be better, right? If I book you
later?"
Right? Right? Right, guys?
I mean, it's Imagine I fly all the way there and you're like,
"I don't like you very much." Also, you want to play meow. I'm
looking for lemons. That would be really unfortunate. Yes, I
don't think that would happen though. I guess at least I'm only
there for a day. It's like a trial run. If you don't like me,
I can be returned and shipped off, so to speak. What? LOL. Well,
yeah, it would definitely be like less pressure and stuff for
both of us. Yeah, plus macarons. Oh, so maybe she's still going
to fly in for one day? Ultimately, I didn't go because my German
passport had expired and due to you're not allowed to travel
to the EU on your UK passport if you have an EU one, even if
it's expired.
When he invited me to go to Paris, he said he'd pay for everything,
food, accommodation, flights, just like he did to other girls
who went to Paris. No idea how he was going to juggle multiple
girls over a few days.
Uh-oh. Yeah, she's got the Elfi stuff in here. And they're going
to compare notes. I swear if it's like him trying to ship her
over in time based on well, the Elfi girl is going to go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. No, no, no. I We pointed this out already woke
up today that it's like the Elfi girl probably said yes around
this time. By some crazy coincidence, I found out Elfi Leya had
been invited to Paris by him and then honestly DM'd her to ask
her if she was in a similar situation to
Sorry if this seems super random, but are you going to Paris
because someone invited you and offered to pay for the tickets
to meet you? Unfortunately, Elfi Leya has her DMs off so she
didn't see it. Honestly wish I tried harder to get in contact
with her, but I was scared to. What if they were friends and
nothing happened? I don't want to risk losing what I thought
was the beginning of a relationship over my insecurities. So,
I chose to stick to my stick my head in the sand and believe
him when he reassured me there there was no one else. Below are
receipts of me confiding in my friend about the situation and
talking about how I already asked him if he was doing something
of this nature with other people. Amusingly and amusingly enough,
I used the word harem. Guess I wasn't far off. I point-blank
asked him if he had a harem or
Or he was or was doing this with other girls and said I wouldn't
mind if that's the case. I just wanted to know so I knew what
I was getting into. Was it a case of I'm just easy release? I
thought I was special. When was he going to juggle us on different
days? That's crazy. Oh, what was he going to juggle us on different
days? That's
That is kind of crazy, man.
That is kind of crazy. I'm telling you when he asks for like
the eighth time, "Have you ever been to Paris before?"
Sorry, not the eighth time. For like the second time. After she's
described going to Paris to him multiple times and suggested
things he should do in Paris, that tells you you're not special,
unfortunately, right? Like you shouldn't
I feel like you just don't forget that, man. Anyway, from this
point onwards, you can blame me for being naive, gullible, stupid,
and yeah, maybe that applies. I really liked him. I enjoyed spending
time with him and he made me laugh a lot, complimented me, and
made me happy. I rationalized it as how could he possibly do
that if he didn't really like me and I wasn't the only one.
After telling him I was an only child multiple times, he repeatedly
thought I had a sibling. Dude, it's crazy how I say something.
I'm seeing something in the and then it just comes out in the
document. It's like, "Yes." I'm sorry, that's the That's a massive
red flag,
It's very obvious.
Dude, that's crazy.
That's nuts.
From this point onwards, you can blame me for being naive, gullible,
stupid, and yeah, maybe that applies. Oh, wait. We read that.
We're on to the messages. Ah. We spent another evening. So, this
is just after Christmas 2025.
Oh, we spent another evening together watching Fallout. We laugh
a lot and have fun. Then there's the things that make me like
he forgot I told him I was an only child. I don't know, man.
I really really don't. Hmm, I don't know either. I feel like
there's something that could be easy to forget, but also not
really.
He also told me more stuff about his family and himself.
Uh I feel like there's something that could be easy to forget,
but also not
When I told him he was surprised I told him he was surprised
and said he thought I had one sibling. And today it was the same.
He thought I had one
So maybe it's one of those things where you gaslight yourself
into the wrong answer. Dude, I Perhaps, yeah. The person doesn't
even believe that.
Okay, it's at least Yeah, it's at least clicking for her that
like hey, this guy like literally doesn't remember me very
He's mixing her up. He is mixing her up, After he was back from
the TFT attorney, I had I asked if he was doing this sort of
thing with anyone else or talking to anyone else. He denied it
again and said he wasn't involved romantically with anyone else.
I trusted him. He also invited me to go to his home in Vegas
again, unsure how the logistics of that would pan out seeing
as he had a girlfriend living there, but nothing he did is particularly
logical. I asked this in a voice call, but I I mean, to be honest,
am I the only person who wouldn't put it past Saikouno to get
an Airbnb and like take framed photos of himself? Like he's just
got a big bag of framed photos of himself and like friends. And
he just gets an Airbnb and he just goes and hangs these up all
over the place.
Does anyone think that's beyond I don't think so. That doesn't
even sound like it'd be hard. So she knows he has a girlfriend?
No, she knows now that he has a girlfriend, right? Cuz it became
She is thinking that he's a player, that he is having these same
conversations with other women. Why Airbnb? Just get a bang apartment.
Maybe. Maybe maybe. After he was back from the TFT attorney,
I asked again if he was doing this sort of thing. We read this.
Okay. He also invited me to go to his home in Vegas, unsure how
the logistics would pan out seeing as he has a girlfriend living
there, but nothing he did is particularly logical. I asked this
in a voice call, but I do have receipts of me venting to my friends.
I had no experience with this sort of thing, so I was getting
guy advice from her. Secondhand account of me confiding in my
friend after I talked to him on call and he once again stated
it was only me. Yeah, we had a pretty good chat about, you know,
what's going on. Woah, like the Elfi Leya lady? Or like you guys'
situation? Hmm, no, but what we talked about confirmed that at
least. He's sticking to his story of it's just me. And he would
be jealous if I was, you know, talking to other guys. OH,
>> He wants the one-sided open thing. Oh, boy. This guy's
been watching red pill. Dude, this guy's
This guy has been on some red pill [__] That's very
very rough. It's very rough, dude. That's That's tough to see,
okay?
Um is he still just a cheater?
Yeah, no. Me being is just a stupid way to look at it. Again,
you you guys are like oh, is he still just a cheater? That's
why it's to call it a cheating drama. That's why I'm starting
to lean Now with this, I'm back into predatory is fine. Predator
predator predatory, totally appropriate for this guy.
Absolutely 100% appropriate. Holy The just cheating characterization
is and you guys are forever accepting it if you did. Obviously
you didn't if you watch me, okay? I just I absolutely hate when
people are like oh, is he It's just cheating, right? It's just
behavior. No, it's like systematically destroying the trust the
ability the the ability to trust in other people. Not caring
about them at all. Just being a total piece of [__]
It's like it's And again, this
for no reason, okay? For no reason.
Like there's some insecurity going on here or something because
this girl said I wouldn't even care, just tell me so I know,
right?
We stopped here and he'd be jealous if I was talking to other
guys. That's another thing. If he said this and I have no reason
to believe that he didn't say this, by the way. Oh, I'd be jealous
if you were talking to other guys.
That is explicitly like trying to reserve somebody for yourself
when you have no intention of of doing the same for them. Okay?
Need advice. I'm here. Sorry, just woke up. He's not two-timing
me, but if he does me around a bit, I think he has become used
to being the most important person, so everyone just does what
he wants when needed, but like I'm waking up at 5:00 a.m. cuz
you said we'd hang out and then we just don't hang out and you
don't even apologize till I make a deal out of it. That's just
crappy. I mean, she is
I don't know. It sucks that this person ended up somehow like
mentally broken early in life cuz they're at least picking up
the signs. They're realizing what's going on. Not letting themselves
get gaslit.
You love to see that. It's like a functional person here exists
somewhere that is beyond what most people on the internet are
capable of,
I'm rooting for this person. They're just crappy. So I stood
my ground and was like nah and went to sleep. I don't know whether
to text him and be like good morning cuz normally he texts me
good morning. No, no, no, no. Here But this is just him ignoring
me once again. This is the thing. This is why And again, this
is insecurity from the other person. What they're going to do
is they're going to know that you are They're going to make sure
that you only have them. Right? So your focus is on them. That's
what they want. They want your undying love and affection. And
they're going to get that from as many people as they can while
giving nothing back.
Right? And so there is no way that you can win in this situation
cuz if you ignore him, he's already set it up, so he's got other
love and affection coming in and you're not going to get any
of the things you want. Like there is no winning for this girl
now. Even if she ignores him when he's a piece of [__]
it's like over cuz there's no buying from the other person. There's
no buying from the other side. It's empty from the other side
without making it obvious that it's empty. If you are buddies
and you make it very clear you have like upfront boundaries and
expectations and that's all it is, then nobody's mad, right?
Nobody's put out. You can't be a bro with a roster. Well, it's
not even like I don't even think having a roster is wrong, but
just let the person know. That's all. Just let them know you're
not my person. You shouldn't be relying on me for like emotional
comfort and emotional stability because I'm not going to be there
for you. I got other things. But again, it's just that total
lack of concern for other regular people. Complete and utter
lack of concern. Not worried about it. Just no feeling for this
other person. Nothing. That's why scum is appropriate. This guy
is scum.
It's very obvious he's scum. Yeah, it's so easy to not be this
kind of scum and he is just total scum. God, I
I'm sorry. I I'm not going to do this very much today cuz I did
it yesterday, but I'm so thoroughly vindicated.
I'm so thoroughly vindicated on every read I had this entire
time.
Uh he said I should come out in a month or so his current once
his current flavor of the month game he's playing it with his
friend entire friend group comes down cuz he's streaming it for
like 10 hours straight then playing it off stream, but disrespect
my time at least a little, you know. I see what you mean.
Money and gifts. He sent me money once as a Christmas present.
I didn't like him because of his money and never asked him for
money. I think this is relevant as it's another example of Saikouno's
pattern of sending hundreds of dollars to girls he was invested
in at the time.
What? Oh my god, I didn't see see it yet. Well, I hope you like
question I've only been here. No, you don't call him a cuz he's
like talking cuz he's like
A or because he's showing some romantic interest in a girl who's
17.
Again, you don't know when he found out she was 17. You do know
he eventually finds out she was 17, but you don't know when he
figured that out, what he knew at the time. You would need more
information there. And she's not even trying to paint him as
a She's just saying obviously the interactions are inappropriate.
Given what he know what she knows now. That that's the way he
talks when he is trying to [__] somebody. She was
17. She was 17 in the first DMs in this
Oh, I get a gift. Probably good thing you didn't see it yet.
It's your PayPal, so he's sending her cash.
What the heck? That's so nice, but you don't have to do that.
I just sends I just like spending time with you. Wait. What do
you mean I can't get it? Is it something I have to buy? Well,
I mean I don't have your address or anything. I was just going
to send you money for it. Oh, I see. I mean, yeah. And I feel
I don't know. I feel bad though. I love giving gifts, but I suck
at accepting
All right, so got her gift and it's not a competition. Hopefully
it works for your new graphics card. Psych. ETF.
That's so much. You didn't have to. Holy moly, are you sure?
Thank you. Oh my god. Are you sure like are you sure sure? I
think you can get a 5070 or something at least.
Uh how much a 5070 cost? Around Around 900 to 1,000 dollars US.
Communication. After the public allegations. Ah, this is going
to be a good section. This is going to be good. I'm going to
like this. Okay? Cuz I saw somebody post the screenshot from
this and oh boy, it looked rough.
If I Well, I mean I glanced, so it's possible I didn't understand
it, but we'll see. After everything got made public, I reached
out to him to try to find some closure. Part of me wanted to
make him feel how it felt to get stabbed in the back or at least
to feel a fraction of the pain I felt. I was hurt, disgusted,
and angry that he probably forgot about me somewhere in the sea
of other girls he was talking to. I wanted him to know how it
felt to believe someone and to believe someone and trust them
when they were only acting under false pretenses. Dude, it's
like This is so Dude, this is the most mentally healthy person
who's able to explain exactly how they feel wronged,
It's crazy that they started this document. They're like I'm
like totally mentally broken. Proceeds to like lay out their
thoughts and feelings and how they feel like like hurt perfectly
in in no uncertain terms. It's like the most mentally healthy
Google document I've ever read in my entire life. It's it's I
There's no way I could It's crazy how good it is. Okay, we got
it. We got to keep going. I wanted to him to know how it felt
to believe someone and trust them when they were only acting
under false pretenses. I know it was morally wrong of me and
selfish, but I was still I was and still am angry. It was all
about him, how sorry he how he was sorry, how he was only human,
how he was going through a lot. Watching him dodge accountability,
continuing to lie even when caught, truly showed me what kind
of person he is, one without remorse or regard for those he used
as toys for his own
That's That's who he is. That's absolutely who he is. I hope
this I hope this helps her. I I I I'll say if you are somebody
who like ruminates and stuff and like spirals and stuff like
this, it's not going to help, which sucks. You could know precisely
I feel like she could know precisely why this guy is bad
and it won't help, but I hope it does.
When corroborating his apology with the other girls, he pretty
much repeated parts to the point we thought we had he had a formula
and replaced certain words to tailor it to each girl. Work smarter,
not harder, I guess. Oh god, they're all comparing notes, too.
I This probably isn't over. Like we're probably going to see
more.
You know what I'm saying? We're probably going to see more. And
this girl, I think she she downplayed how weird the DMs when
she was 17 were. And I think there's
I don't know if I'm quite there. I think you would need to see
a lot more of the conversations. You need to see like the broad
characterization of the conversation instead of just the
But he absolutely made multiple comments
comments when she was underage to her. Okay? So, he soft-played
that. He could have played that a lot harder, I think, and people
would have run with it. Anyway, we we keep going. Personally,
I don't know Oh, we'll read the whole thing. How you holding
up? That's a pretty brutal exposé. Not well, I'm sorry.
Dude, do you think he even understands like what's going on in
her head at all? It's unfortunate.
I don't know what your mental is like but right now, but please
don't do anything stupid.
can I ask something?
I'm alive and yes, you can.
Why'd you lie? I asked you point-blank if you were doing this
kind of thing with other
I believe I even used the phrase more power to you if so. At
the time, wasn't
Oh, at the time I talked to you, I
When I was talking to someone else, that's when we stopped talking
as much.
I'm sure you could tell.
I'm sorry. I know this isn't nice to hear, but you deserve the
truth at I'm sorry for hurting you.
I am sorry
for hurting you.
>> Well, let's not lie. You invited me to Paris while inviting
two other girls that I know of.
You rejected me there, but I did stop talking to you as much.
No, I didn't. You said it you couldn't extend the trip and that
even if I had to that and well, sorry, and what even if I had
that proves I'm not the only one what even if I had that what
does that prove even if I had? I'm not the only one you were
talking to if you had multiple other people ready to be deployed.
I've known you for 6 years. Can you not at least be a little
more truthful? I
I'm telling you
I'm telling you it.
But for the original question,
I don't fully know why. A combination of wanting to say things
to make you happy, being afraid and insecure to make you upset.
It's not a simple answer. I'm sorry, it's hard to put together
especially right now. I haven't been having a good time.
By the way, I don't fully know why. That's I don't I don't even
recognize myself anymore.
I don't know what I've I don't know how I got here. I have I
don't know who I am. I don't know what's going on. Guys, I don't
even recognize myself anymore.
Who have I become? What is happening?
What is happening? [screaming]
Sad. Sad.
Disgusting degenerate
lying scum. I Oh, I've got to actually break TOS reading this.
Okay, we keep reading. I said I wouldn't care if you were, just
just that would affect how I then proceeded with the situation.
How would tell you telling me anything make me upset when I outright
said I didn't care and that was your business.
I know.
I know. You were good. I'm sorry I couldn't be.
You didn't deserve it. Oh, I'm sorry I couldn't be. Hold on.
I I need to deliver that all as one line?
>> Take Take Take Take Take two. Take two.
I know.
You were good.
I'm sorry I couldn't be. You didn't deserve it. I don't expect
you to forgive me, but if there's anything I'd ask for, it's
that I did genuinely >> enjoy spending time with you. And
I'm sorry for hurting you and not communicating properly.
You're being dramatic. Yeah, I cried a lot, but I kind of knew.
Why else would I ask you twice about it?
Sorry for the drama. It's been a hard
Dude, you are who you are. It just made
I'm a human, too. So,
I'm aware and I hope you are doing as well as you could be. I
had lots of fun with you, too.
It's just hard to be more I'm just crushed right now. It's hard
for me to do anything. I don't know what's happening.
Wait, where did it all go wrong?
I don't know if this was a persona or not, but either way, we
had some good laughs and I appreciate that. What you did sucks
or sorry, what you did sucks, but it is what it is. I'm not the
biggest victim here. You made me feel special and that was nice
and I've met so many people through you. It wasn't It was fun
spending time together.
Be so sad if all those memories
Even though you killed me so many times in games, you maniac.
He thinks he's turning it around.
He thinks he's TURNING IT AROUND.
Cody Cody coming down. Cody coming down from reading this.
Yeah, well, you deserved it, you conniving rock.
You would do the exact same to me for content and we both know
it. I did. Thank you for messaging me. That was the closest thing
to a smile I've had remembering that.
Good thing you have those investments, I guess. I mean, as sad
as I am, I still care about you. You've hurt so many people,
but you are still a human as you said. Maybe I'm too optimistic
and naive, but hopefully with therapy and time everyone will
heal. And hey, you had a pretty good run all things considered.
You probably should have vetted / picked a little better.
the dispassionate analysis should be sending his like his warning
levels up through the ceiling. Right? The The dis- He thinks
this is like her empathizing with him. It's like a totally dispassionate
analysis of how this has
And it's it shows what a narcissist he is that he doesn't even
understand that these These are like the most cutting things
you could hear. It's she just
she just knows exactly who you are. It's very very funny.
It's life. >> It sounds like you think I'd never plan on
coming back.
I mean, you'd have to have balls of steel to come back right
now.
Not right now, of course, but thank you for worrying about me
still.
Thanks for checking up so much.
I messaged you twice. That's not a
More than many, but thank you.
You didn't do anything illegal, did you? Not that you should
tell me if you did. Again, what you did, it sucks, but people
don't act logically, they act emotionally. I hope she understands
that there's a very good chance that he doesn't remember anything
about you. I would That's brutal, by the way. Totally brutal
and I understand how this is like cutting it hurts and it sucks.
It's the worst feeling, okay? I get it. But he does not He probably
doesn't even remember the level of the emotional investment he
fostered that he like built up over time.
uh again, what you did, it sucks, but people don't act logically,
they act emotionally. Right now, they're hurt, so emotions take
the wheel. I still consider you a friend, maybe that's wrong.
Well, someone I care about your
I didn't do anything illegal. Thank you for still caring.
Maybe I don't deserve it, but I really needed to hear that. Thank
you.
In response to me offhandedly saying you had a pretty good run,
he says, "And it sounds like you you think I'd plan never plan
on coming back." That stood out because even in the middle of
everything coming out, he seemed to already be thinking about
returning. That felt jarring, in my opinion. Someone who is genuinely
focused on reflection and accountability would not be thinking
about a comeback at that moment.
Yeah, that's 100% correct. Yeah.
It's It's actually crazy that
it Once he thinks she's and he can't see it cuz again, complete
narcissist. So, I don't know like I'm not doing a diagnosis.
I'm just saying narcissistic tendencies where he can't even see
like how
how kind of done she is just because of the way she's speaking.
Such a dumb thing to harp on. She baited that response with the
you had a nice
Well, hold on. What did What did she mean by you have a you had
a nice run?
Cuz I think what she meant was
she meant in terms of cheating, you had a good run. That's like
a tongue-in-cheek comment on cheating. You probably should have
picked vetted a little bit better. What are you talking about?
What do you What Oh, going to Cody spike again. Oh, no. Oh, no.
He was thinking about coming back. She was clearly not talking
about coming back. Boy, oh boy. Okay. All right. My closing thoughts.
I'm going to shut off the music for this one. We'll go through
the closing thoughts really quickly.
Let's see them. Let's hear them. What's going on here?
My closing thoughts. I'm really sorry to anyone I've disappointed.
I trusted someone I only had positive interactions with for years
and honestly, I like the attention. It made me feel special.
I feel gross and disgusted that I exposed myself and was vulnerable
around someone who didn't actually care for me. I really was
just another number added to the list. If you choose to not want
to watch or support me anymore, I understand and want to thank
you for your time or for the time you have given me. I wrestled
with speaking about this because I didn't want people to see
me differently, lose the friends I made via him, or be attacked.
Hopefully, by offering this information, people will see it wasn't
just one or two girls. He has done this to so many girls over
the years. We were all put in a situation where our consent was
given based on a lie. No one knew he had a girlfriend and that
he was messaging and sleeping around with multiple girls. I'm
so deeply sorry to all of the people you hurt. You all deserve
so much better, and you weren't the problem.
Yeah, the sad thing about the internet is probably there's still
going to be a whole bunch of completely degenerate losers who
will joke and be like, "Saikou no so awesome for this. Saikou
no so" Dude, all of you people are just weird weird scum. Just
weird scum.
Well, maybe not all of you. Some of you just are like two You're
like sheep who just sort of like echo the previous sheep sentiment,
right? You're like a chain a long chain of of cellular sheep
that you have like no opinions of your own. You're just like,
"Huh, funny meme. I say funny meme, too." Which, you know, that's
an existence, I guess.
Never thinking for yourself. That's a That is an existence, I
suppose.
XQC? I don't know if that's XQC. I will say this changes a lot.
You think he covers his mouth while he's up and down the West
Coast? He covers his mouth. I hope that's all he's not all he's
covering.
Anyway, okay, that's the document. Man, I think this is way better
produced than the previous ones. Um it doesn't strain outside
the bounds on anything. It doesn't make like crazy allegations.
I think even the fact that she wants to put in the Oh, whoops.
I just moved my sh- I just moved my browser. She wants to add
the fact that she was underage when they first met, but she doesn't
overplay it. She doesn't say like, "Hey, I'm I'm I was underage
and this was evil." In fact, in her Twitter message, she explicitly
says, "Well, it wasn't really anything." And then you find out
it wasn't it wasn't
Right? It was something. It was weird.
Youngest victim wrote the best doc. Well, she's not 17 now. I
think she's 24 25 now. She was 17 in 2020. Leaves the girlfriend
out, too? Yeah, sure. Now, this was um this was actually really
really well written and I think paints him in the exact light
This was perfect. This was like pitch perfect in terms of painting
out the predatory behavior and why, by the way, this is what
This is what I was picking up on. This is This is how I felt
reading first document. I'm like, "Oh, I can see exactly who
this guy is." Like it's it's total scum behavior. And a bunch
of big influencers will want to sweep for it because all of those
people just want to chain 18 17 18 19 20-year-olds. That's what
they want to do. That's what their goal is, right?
So, they'll defend this because they have to defend this because
this is precisely the behavior they want to engage in either
in the future or that they're engaging in now.
The way I described this pattern to you every single day we've
covered this drama, and now you see it bear out one to one. Know
that I see these It's okay.
We do see We see it. We see it. Do people like this hit extra
closer to home or are you just extra annoyed by all the incel
tards? They actually explicitly don't hit closer to home. Cuz
for all of his faults,
nobody's ever accused Destiny a single time. I assume you're
talking about Destiny. This isn't like Destiny behavior. Destiny
doesn't do this thing.
This is like maybe one of the only positive things you can say
about this person about Destiny being a degenerate is he doesn't
engage in this sort of like lying I'm going to get you into a
relationship thing. That's so No, it it's like I don't see I
see Techtone when I read this stuff. Like I think I think of
like Techtone viewers. Like they're the kind of people who just
see a woman feels like they were a victim in some way and they
are immediately like all the way in against the woman before
they think anything.